we fight to protect our kids and this
planet from climate change
we also create millions of good-paying
jobs we need to guarantee
and do what every other major country on
earth does
and that is to guarantee healthcare to
all people as
a human right healthcare is a human
right
not a privilege we need to make sure
that all of our young people in this
country have the right
to get a higher education regardless of
their income
and yes we need to make sure that the
wealthiest people
and large corporations stop paying their
fair share
of taxes now i know that my republican
colleagues
have a different view i suspect that
senator graham will disagree with one or
two things that i have said may be wrong
about that
but at a time of massive income and
wealth inequality
uh i do not believe that we should be
giving more tax breaks to the rich
in fact amazingly enough maybe we can
discuss this
several of my republican colleagues in
the senate including majority leader
mcconnell
introduced a bill to repeal the estate
tax
legislation that would provide 1.7
trillion dollars in tax breaks
to the billionaire class while doing
nothing to helping working families or
family farms
let's be clear repealing the estate tax
would only benefit
the top one tenth of one percent who
inherit over
11.7 million dollars 99.9 percent of the
american people
would not receive a penny if this
legislation became law so
bottom line is uh today we are
discussing a huge
issue that has broad implications for
every person in this country and i look
forward
to our panelists uh presentation and to
the discussion
uh senator graham thank you mr chairman
uh one thing we will agree on is that
you believe this
you have been the most consistent voice
i think in the country
uh over a long period of time on issues
like this
we do had have disagreement but i
like working with people who believe
what they believe
now here's some common ground i think
most of us don't want the consolidation
of wealth and power
to lie in the hands of the few uh
through
ill-gotten gain to monopolies
through unfair trade practices through
criminal enterprise
market manipulation but if you can make
your money legally and fairly
good for you and that brings us to the
question of big tech
i don't know what we do about this mr
chairman but the question for me is
have we let too much power consolidate
in the hands of big tech
is it a virtual monopoly in terms of
flow of information
and have we uh allowed these uh
new technologies to become the modern
version of robin bear
robber barons of the last century and i
would
like to talk more about that i don't
know if you need to break these
companies up or not
the section 230 and other things we need
to revisit
but generally speaking it's been a
capitalist nation
uh and hope it remains so uh with
regulation
to prevent environmental abuse and make
sure people play by the rules
to me the government plays a role in
keeping the the water
in the banks when people start creating
monopolies that's unfair to other
competitors when people cheat and scheme
and
get rich off bad business practices uh
that's something we all should be
concerned about
but the gallup poll company has been
asking americans what they think most
important
problem facing the country every month
for a long time
and the latest survey 26 percent said it
was the
coronavirus just one percent said it was
the gap between rich and poor
now how can that be i actually believe
that
i believe that most americans don't
spend their time
wondering about how to take from
somebody else they're wondering about
how do i get ahead
and they're looking for opportunity and
they should be demanding that
opportunity
one thing that i think we can start
focusing on
is how do you lift people up uh who have
been in poverty how do you prevent
present better opportunity there's the
way described by the chairman and i
think the other way that i like is
senator scott who's focused on
enterprise
opportunity zones and blighted
neighborhoods
making sure that there's tax advantages
for businesses like amazon and others
to go into these neighborhoods and
increase wages
by having better business opportunity
but all of us have one thing in common
here on this committee
we had good educations and if you want
to level the playing field for america
make sure that every kid regardless of
zip code has an
adequate opportunity to be well educated
and i believe in public school systems
i'm a product of it
but the question becomes what happens
when a public school fails time and time
again
what are the things that we can do to
level that playing field
so here's what the census bureau said
that the poverty rate hit an all-time
low in 2019
and that between 2017 and 2019
in income equality actually declined
that uh before the pandemic the
unemployment rate was at a 50-year low
rates for african-american hispanic and
people with disabilities
hit their lowest unemployment levels on
record
wages were rising at their fastest pace
in years and they were rising
fastest for blue collar workers so
there's two different models being
suggested here
and i think the model that we're
suggesting is that
accumulation of wealth through
monopolies and
other unfair trade practices or
manipulation of markets or criminal
enterprises we should all
be against that but like bill gates you
invented something
a lot of people want
amazon they found a way to get you
products that you want
the problem mr chairman is online
shopping may put
brick and mortar businesses out
so one of the things that i've been
focused on is making sure that sales
taxes
are collected from online vendors like a
brick and mortar business like my family
had
because that would create a tax
advantage for online
uh businesses so i want a level playing
field in terms of regulation and taxes
and educational opportunity
and i think that's the role of the
government not
picking who gets this and who gets that
and
what is too much money i think that's
the
if the government gets in that business
it will do more harm than good
but i'm looking forward to working with
you on this and many other issues
and quite frankly i'm enjoying this
committee because we're talking about
things that matter
so thank you senator graham thanks very
much
um now we're going to go to our
witnesses and we have some great
witnesses
this morning and i thank all of them for
their willingness to be with us
first we have robert reich
many of you will remember that bob reich
is the former labor secretary secretary
of labor under president clinton into my
view
one of the great secretaries of labor
this country has ever had
uh professor reich is the author of
numerous books including
the system who rigged it how we fix it
and is currently
a professor of public policy at the
university of california
berkeley uh professor reich thank you so
much
for being with us this morning
uh well thank you very much mr chairman
and members of the committee
with your permission i will simply
provide my testimony and submit it
to the committee also several charts
that i think the committee might find
very useful uh let me just say and i'm
going to summarize very quickly
uh even before the pandemic america had
the widest
inequalities of income and wealth we've
had in a century
and wider than any other developed
nation
the median wage in the united states has
barely budged
for 40 years when you adjust for
inflation
even though the economy of the united
states is almost three times larger
and more than half americans earn so
little
that they have to live paycheck to
paycheck now this is something new
in the history of at least post-world
war ii
america we've never seen the degree of
inequality we're now
experiencing increasingly the economy's
gains have gone to the top the richest
one
tenth of one percent mr chairman as you
said i want to just underscore this
there is just one tenth of one percent
has almost as much wealth
as the bottom 90 put together
and again the compensation packages of
the top executives big companies ceos
have soared from an average of 20 times
that of the typical worker 40 years ago
or
60 times when i was labor secretary to
320 times
today uh and you know the the pandemic
has just made all of this a much more
stark america's 660 billionaires
have together become 1.3 trillion
dollars
richer this would be enough by the way
this 1.3 trillion
that they have gained during the past
year would be enough for them to give
every american
a 3 900 check and still be as rich
as they were before the pandemic the
american rescue plan
just enacted is helpful in this regard
but i think it's very important
for this committee to look at the
underlying structure of power
power is a word that we don't use very
often when we talk about the economy
but there has been a huge shift in power
over the last 40 years
a shift toward very large corporations
and senator graham is absolutely right
there has got to be much more emphasis
on fighting monopolies and it's
monopolies both
in terms of big high-tech companies also
monopolies uh in terms of high finance
uh big pharma i mean you go around this
country today and you see
more concentration more economic
concentration
than we've seen at any time in the last
60 years
and also that economic concentration
translates
into political power we've got a
severely imbalanced political economy
we have fewer than seven percent of our
workers are in unions today 50 years ago
over a third of workers in the private
sector were unionized
50 years ago giant corporations didn't
have the power to suppress
prevailing wages they didn't have
platoons of washington lobbyists
which way which they have today another
very important indication of what's
happening
and what's happened is that before the
1980s
the main driver of profits and the stock
market
was economic growth but research has
shown
and i include some of that research in
my testimony
that since the late 1980s the major
means
by which corporations have increased
profits and stock prices
has been by keeping payroll down
and and that has hurt the working class
i mean the working class in this country
has taken it on the chin the working
class needs
uh to understand uh that this is about
you know there's not a market someplace
in uh
in in the in the atmosphere in the in
the
in nature i mean the market is a human
creation
uh and what has happened as power has
shifted
dramatically toward big corporations and
against workers and against
workers because they don't have unions
to represent them you have a change in
the structure of the market
a dramatic change and to rebalance
the economy is necessary but to provide
more vigorous use of anti-trust
substantially higher taxes on growing
accumulations of income and wealth
stronger labor protections to enable
workers uh to join together
uh to gain higher wages and benefits and
also greater restrictions
on the use of private and corporate
wealth to influence to influence
political decisions uh i have many much
more to say but i
i just want to and i will uh eager um
eagerly
await your questions uh mr chairman and
uh and members of the committee
mr secretary thank you very much uh
our second witness is sarah anderson the
director of global economy
project at the institute for policy
studies
ms anderson has studied income and
wealth inequality for years
and is a well-known expert on executive
compensation
ms anderson thanks so much for being
with us
thank you thank you very much for this
opportunity i am sarah anderson with the
institute for policy studies and i've
been researching inequality for more
than 25 years
concentrating on what might be the
single most dramatic driver of that
inequality
the growing gap between ceo and worker
pay
this is a systemic problem in corporate
america
in 1980 the average gap between big
companies ceos and typical worker pay
was 42 to 1.
over the past 20 years that gap has
averaged about 350 to 1.
this growing pay divide is also a driver
of gender and racial disparities
nearly 90 percent of fortune 500 ceos
are white men
while women and people of color are
disproportionately a large share of
low-wage workers
but we all pay a price for this
executive access
back in 2008 executives chasing huge
bonuses
crashed our economy leaving millions
homeless and
and without jobs in the wake of that
disaster
senator john mccain and many other
lawmakers called for a 400
000 cap on pay at all companies
receiving taxpayer assistance
but corporations and wall street banks
not only blocked that proposal
they designed compensation packages to
help executives rebound more quickly
than ordinary americans today we're
living through a period of even greater
national suffering
and a period when frontline workers have
proved how essential they are
to our economy and our health and yet uh
once again many corporate leaders are
focused on bending the rules to protect
massive ceo paychecks let me give you a
few
examples at coca-cola none of the top
executives met their bonus targets last
year but the board gave them all bonuses
anyway
the ceo wound up with 18 million in
total compensation
over 1 600 times as much as the
company's typical worker pay
or look at carnival remember how they
stranded their employees on their cruise
ships for months without pay
meanwhile the board gave the ceo a
special retention and incentive award
that lifted his overall pay to more than
13 million dollars
a 22 percent increase over 2019
at tyson foods 12 000 frontline workers
contracted covid last year
but that didn't stop the board from
giving executive stock grants to make up
for the fact that they hadn't met their
bonus targets
one of these executives was company
chair john tyson
who was hardly in dire need he's seen
his personal wealth
increase 62 percent during the pandemic
to 2.4 billion dollars
research by my institute for policy
studies colleagues and americans for tax
fairness
shows that the combined wealth of all
660
u.s billionaires has soared by 1.3
trillion during
the pandemic many of them of course owe
their fortunes to their years as ceos
now corporate executives didn't cause
the pandemic in the direct way that
executives reckless behavior led to the
2008 crash
but many ceos did make working families
much more vulnerable to the current
crisis
by outsourcing jobs and turning millions
of the jobs that remained
into low-wage part-time work without
benefits
we can and must do better as a nation
than to accept a business model that
creates prosperity for the few
and precarity for the many this isn't
just bad for workers it's also bad for
business
research shows that having these extreme
gaps undermines morale
which lowers productivity in this time
of crisis
we also must see common ground and we
have common ground when it comes to ceo
pay
in fact a stanford survey found that 52
of republican voters actually want to
cap ceo pay
relative to worker pay i'll end with a
few policy solutions that are far more
moderate than what a
majority of republicans support first
the tax excessive ceo pay act
this would increase taxes on
corporations with huge gaps between ceo
and worker pay
and this would create an incentive to
both rein in pay at the top
and lift up worker wages all while
generating an estimated 150 billion
in revenue over 10 years companies that
have small gaps
less than 50 to 1 they wouldn't owe one
more dime under this proposal
another way to generate revenue while
curbing executive excess would be
through a financial transaction tax
this would curb the short-term
speculation that has inflated wall
street executive bonuses
while doing nothing for main street we
could also leverage the power of the
public purse by
giving corporations with narrow gaps a
leg up in government contracting
corporate boards have shown us after the
financial crash and during the pandemic
that we can't rely on them to do the
right thing when it comes to ceo pay
this is a problem that affects
all of us and we need responsible policy
solutions
thank you very much i look forward to
your questions
ms anderson thank you very much um
next uh our next panelist is jennifer
bates
ms bates is an amazon worker at the
bessemer alabama fulfillment center
she and her co-workers are trying to
form a union in amazon with the retail
wholesale and department store union
i invited both ms bates and amazon
founder and executive chairman jeff
bezos
i'm very happy miss bates agreed to
testify
unlike mr bezos miss bates thank you
very much for being with us
um thank you chairman sanders
rankin members graham and members of
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today
amazon brags it pays workers above the
minimum wage
what they don't tell you is what those
jobs are really like
and they certainly don't tell you that
they can afford to do much
better for the workers working at amazon
warehouse is no easy thing
the shifts are long the pace is super
fast
you're constantly being watched and
monitored they seem to think you are
another
machine i started working at amazon in
may
of 2020 not too long after they opened
by my third day i was hurting i looked
around and saw it wasn't just me
i mentioned it to my sister who also
worked there at the time
and she just told me it only gets worse
at amazon you are on your feet walking
all the time
and climbing stairs to get to your
station and move products
we have only 30 minute breaks during a
10-hour shift
two thirty minute breaks during the uh
ten hour shift which is not long enough
to give you time to rest the the place
is huge the size of
few football fields just walking the
long way to the bathroom and back
eats up precious break time my
co-workers and i
older younger middle-aged people limp
and climbing up and down the stairs in
the four-floor building
when i first came to amazon to work i
noticed there was one elevator for human
use
when i tried to use it a co-worker
stopped me and told me
that we were not allowed to use it then
i noticed that
around the facility there were plenty of
elevators
but the signs say material only
no riders i can believe that
they built a facility with so many
elevators for materials and make the
employees take the spares
on a huge four flight facility the work
itself is also grueling we have to keep
up with the pace
my work day feels like a nine hour
intense workout
every day and they track our every move
if your computer isn't scanning you get
charged with being
time off task from the onset
i learned that if i work too slow
or had too much time off task i could be
disciplined or even
fired like a lot of workers it was too
much
for my sister and she ended up quitting
i thought there should be another way
i mean why can't a large and wealthy
company do better
for their workers amazon has made
tons of money during the pandemic jeff
bezos is the richest man in the world
and now he's even richer than to us
workers
yet they expect us not to expect
anything we didn't already have
before we started working there like we
do not deserve better
amazon's going to poor communities
claiming that they want to help the econ
the economic growth that should mean
paying its employees
a living wage and benefits that truly
match the cost of living
and ensure workers work in safe and
healthy conditions
because we are not robots designed to
only live to work
we work to live we deserve to live laugh
and love and have a fulfilling life
we the workers deserve to be treated
with dignity and respect
and deserve to be given the same
commitment that we give to the job every
day we go in
we get 100 at work but it feels like
we're being given back
only 30 we're committed to make
sure the customers get a nice package
the whole product in a couple of days
but who is looking out for us
we the workers made the billions for
amazon i often say we're the
billionaires we just don't get to spend
any of it
we first started to talk about
unionizing one day during a break
one guy said they wouldn't be doing
these things to us if we had a union
people were upset about the breaks being
too short and not have enough time to
rest
about being humiliated by having to go
through random security checks
going to our breaks to make sure we're
not stealing merchandise and then not
even giving us
the time back that for our breaks
others didn't like that they never
actually spoke to a manager
they just got messages on an app or by a
text
it's also so impersonal and at times
just plain weird
and then there's the issue of job
security
people are concerned about people
getting fired for no real reason
and not being given the opportunity to
speak to anybody at amazon
about it they deny us good working
condition and claim
we should be happy with what we have and
then go around spending millions to tell
us
we don't need a union as soon as amazon
found out about the union
they started going hard trying to stop
the union drive
we were forced into what they call union
education meetings
we had no choice but to attend them not
given an opportunity to decline
they would last for as much as an hour
and we'd have to go
sometime several times a week the
company would just hammer
on different reasons why the union was
bad for us
and we had to listen if someone spoke up
and disagreed with what the company was
saying they would just shut the meeting
down
and told people to go back to work then
follow up with us
on one-on-one meetings on the floor a
lot of what was said in those meeting
was untrue
like telling people they'd lose their
benefits if they joined the union
it was upsetting to see some of the
younger people who were really on board
with the union
get confused about what was being said
in the meetings
all around the plant amazon had put up
anti-union signs and messages
they sent messages to to workers phones
they even had signs posted in the
bathroom stalls
no place was also off limits no place
seemed safe
despite all that or maybe because of it
we continue to organize and build
support for the union
we do it because we hope with the union
we will finally have
a level playing field we hope we will be
able to talk to someone in hr without
being dismissed
we hope that we will be able to rest
more that there will be change
in the facility to make some of the
stress off our bodies
we're hoping we get a living wage not
just amazon's
minimum wage and be able to provide
better for our families
we hope that they will start to hear us
and see us and treat us like human
beings
it's frustrating that all we want is to
make amazon a better place to work
yet amazon is acting like they are under
attack
maybe if they spent less time and money
trying to stop the union they would hear
what we are saying and maybe they would
create a company
that's as good for workers in our
community
as it is for the shareholders and
executives
thank you for giving me the time to
share my story
ms bates thank you very much uh
our next witness is john letieri
uh who was president and ceo of economic
innovation group
prior to his work at the economic
innovation group mr latieri was the vice
president of public policy
and governor government affairs for a
leading business association
the organization for international
investment mr
thierry thank you very much for being
with us
thank you chairman sanders ranking
member graham
and members of the committee i
appreciate the privilege of testifying
today on the challenge of inequality in
the united states
i believe there are many ways for
congress to work on a bipartisan basis
to tackle economic inequality
and support the needs of low-income and
disadvantaged people i discussed several
such areas in my written testimony
including
promoting economic dynamism and worker
mobility by banning the use of
non-compete agreements
pursuing an aggressive policy of full
employment to boost wages and labor
force participation for workers at the
bottom
and enacting a bold place-based policy
agenda to support struggling regions and
distressed communities
but in the interest of time i want to
focus my open opening comments this
morning on a fourth issue
helping low and moderate-income
americans build wealth through long-term
retirement savings
the us economy is the world's most
powerful engine of wealth creation and
prosperity
but in spite of this the lack of wealth
at the bottom remains a troubling and
persistent fact of life
the numbers are startling the median net
worth for the bottom 25 percent of
american families is a mere 310 dollars
the bottom 50 percent of families own
less than 2 percent of total u.s wealth
one of the central reasons for the
persistent lack of wealth at the bottom
is the lack of adequate retirement
savings among low-income families
the median retirement savings balance
for the bottom fifty percent of american
families is zero dollars
for comparison the median for families
in the top ten percent
is six hundred ten thousand dollars now
the problem here is not that affluent
americans are doing well at saving
but rather the current policy is so
poorly designed to support those most in
need of building wealth
and the reason here is simple retirement
savings policy mostly relies upon
deductions from taxable income that are
little used to americans the bottom
fifty percent of the income distribution
most of whom pay little to no federal
income tax to begin with
so as a result a person making twenty
thousand dollars a year and contributing
the maximum gets
nothing from federal and state tax
incentives while a person earning two
hundred thousand dollars gets over seven
thousand in federal state aid
in other words those who need help
building wealth are the ones most
excluded by current policy
deeply uneven participation retirement
savings also perpetuates the racial
wealth gap
only 35 of hispanic families and only 50
41
of black families hold any retirement
account savings compared to 68
of white families among those that do
have at least some
retirement savings the median white
family holds more than double that of
the meeting hispanic family in the
median black family
so what can be done a number of
noteworthy proposals including for
members of this committee have been put
forward in recent years to address the
dearth of retirement savings
among low-income workers but there is
one option that is both elegant in its
simplicity
and transformative in its potential
benefits and it will be familiar to
every member of congress
and that is to make all low and moderate
income workers eligible for a program
modeled after the federal thrift savings
plan
complete with a match on contributions
up to a certain percentage of income
the tsp is a defined contribution
savings program now available only to
federal employees and members of the
military
in a paper soon to be published by my
organization co-authors dr teresa
geralducci of the new school
and dr kevin hassett former chair of the
white house council of economic advisors
make the case for expanding access to
the tsb to tens of millions of americans
who currently do not enjoy participation
in an employer-sponsored plan they argue
that the design of the tsp makes it an
ideal model for helping low and moderate
income workers build wealth
ensure a comfortable retirement and grow
a nest egg that can be passed on to
future generations
the tsp is an incredibly well designed
program participants enjoy
automatic enrollment a simple menu of
options for investment
an easy user interface very low expense
ratios and matching contributions of up
to five percent of income
along with a number of other features
that when combined have proven to
generate remarkably strong participation
among eligible workers
the beauty of the tsp is that it is a
proven and carefully studied model that
performs exceedingly well
for the very traditionally marginalized
workers that have largely been neglected
by u.s retirement policy participation
rates for example among those with a
high school degree or less
and workers in the bottom one third of
earnings have reached as high as 95
percent
and such workers on average contribute a
significant share of their earnings to
their tsp accounts
in other words the tsp already provides
compelling evidence that low-income
limited education workers will addedly
participate in a well-designed savings
scheme
if it's made available to them creating
such a pathway for working americans to
build wealth through a widely available
and portable program modeled on the tsp
would be a transformative step
towards ensuring that everyone in this
country has a meaningful stake in
national economic growth and prosperity
such a program would be in addition to
not in place of social security
filling the gap in current policy to
support tens of millions of workers
including part-time gig workers
who are most in need of additional
support an early estimate suggests that
the enormous social and economic
benefits generated by this policy could
be achieved at relatively little cost
as the forthcoming paper and subsequent
analyses will demonstrate
boosting incomes wealth and well-being
for those at the bottom is a worthy
policy goal
that should be tackled from a number of
complementary directions and i believe
this is one of the most important
thank you and i look forward to taking
your questions
mr liptieri thank you very much for your
presentation our last witness is scott
wincher
director of poverty studies at the
american enterprise institute
before joining aei dr winship served as
the executive director of the joint
economic comp
uh committee mr winter thank you very
much for being with us
thank you mr chairman chairman sanders
ranking member graham and members of the
committee thank you for inviting me to
appear today to discuss inequality in
the united states
policymakers confront difficult
decisions prioritizing challenges facing
the nation
obviously to the extent that some issue
merits being designated a crisis it
should command the highest levels of
attention
but income and wealth and equality do
not constitute a crisis
the conventional wisdom that inequality
has risen dramatically
is wrong based on influential research
turns out to have suffered from
mismeasurement problems
even if inequality had risen by as much
as as often claimed
over the same period middle class
incomes have risen significantly
and are at all time highs poverty has
fallen sharply and is at an all-time low
other sets of problems deserve more of
our attention twenty years ago this
september thomas piketty
and emmanuel sayez published their first
estimates of income concentration in the
united states
as i discuss in my written testimony
these estimates turned out to have
important flaws
since acknowledged by piketty and
science these figures indicate that the
share of income received by the top 1
percent
rose 14 percentage points between 1979
in 2019 however improved estimates from
gerald otton and david splinter
put the likely increase at just four
points these figures did not take into
account
taxes nor most government transfers in
other words they ignore most of the ways
that federal policy already reduces
inequality
after taxes and transfers otton and
splinter find that the top 1
share rose from 7.2 percent in 1979
to 8.7 in 2017.
as income measurement has improved it
seems ever likelier that the perception
of a crisis in income inequality
stems from statistics that turn out not
to reflect reality
the wealth concentration estimates of
syez and gabriel zukman
have also been influential leading to
calls for wealth taxation
however their research has been
challenged by matthew smith
owen zidar and eric zwick they report an
eight-point rise in the top one percent
share from 1979
to 2016. compared with the 13 point rise
siaz and zuckerman report over the same
years measuring wealth however is
subject to complicated challenges which
i discussed
in my written testimony here i will only
point out that most americans would save
more for retirement
absent the strong likelihood that they
will be able to count on receiving
senior entitlements from the federal
government
if they save more that would show up in
the data's higher wealth
yet we do not count these government
promises in wealth
smith zadar and zwick find that the
share wealth owned by the top
0.1 percent rose from around 9.5 percent
in 1989 to 14 in 2016
but after adding the value of social
security the increase was only
from 8 to 10 even if income or wealth
concentration
had risen more sharply it would matter
whether increasing inequality had come
at the expense of people and families
below the top 1
the fact of the matter is that incomes
below the top have risen significantly
the congressional budget office finds
that median pre-tax household income
rose between 32 and 41 from 1979 to
2017. an increase was 54
to 61 percent after taxes and transfers
that amounts to thirty thousand dollars
in an additional inflation-adjusted
income
according to the official measure the
poverty rate in 2019 was lower than ever
before
among all americans all american
families families headed by a single
woman
non-hispanic whites blacks hispanics and
asians
as i discuss in my written testimony
official statistics are biased in a
variety of ways that dramatically
understate the progress we have made
reducing poverty
poverty among the the children of single
mothers for instance
fell from 49 in 1982 to 18
in 2014 and is lower today
before closing i want to redirect your
attention to two sets of issues that i
would characterize as crises of
opportunity
first is the problem of limited upward
mobility out of poverty
even as we have driven child poverty
rates down that has not resulted in a
greater chance
the children raised in low income
families will make it to the middle
class
the lack of progress boosting upward
mobility is even more worrisome
because it prevents us from narrowing
vast disparities in mobility
between black and white children a
second crisis of
opportunity involves the deterioration
of our association life
relative to 40 or 50 years ago americans
marry less often
live further from family members in
adulthood do fewer things together with
their neighbors
attend religious services less often
join fewer groups and spend less time
with co-workers outside the workplace
economic residential segregation has
worsened
trust in institutions has diminished
single parenthood has increased
along with non-marital birth rates and
divorce
since these problems predate the
increase in inequality and have occurred
as paul
as poverty rates have fallen addressing
them is likely to require
different kinds of policies that would
be considered if the goal were to reduce
inequality
for poverty indeed many policies that
would reduce inequality or short-term
poverty
might be counterproductive in terms of
increasing upward mobility
or reversing declines in association of
life
policymakers should take care in
labeling some economic or social
challenge a crisis
people of course will differ in their
assessment about how serious an issue is
but a crisis that is declared on the
basis of questionable data
and questionable claims about why that
data is important runs the risk of
crowding out more pressing national
problems
is difficult enough identifying
solutions to our problems we cannot let
ourselves
be led astray in prioritizing them thank
you very much
mr machip thank you very much for your
testimony
now we're going to begin the questions
um let me begin uh my questioning
with uh former secretary of labor bob
reich
uh mr secretary uh according to your
testimony
50 years ago general motors was the
largest employer in america
where the typical worker belonged to a
union and made 35
an hour after adjusting for inflation
today america's largest employer is
walmart where over half their workforce
makes less than 15 an hour
and none of their workers belong to a
union how has the decline in union
membership
contributed to the increase in income
inequality
uh mr chairman uh one of the most
dramatic changes
in the united states over the past 60
years
has been declining the decline in the
percentage of private sector workers who
are unionized
uh 60 years ago even in fact 50 years
ago
one-third of all private sector workers
belonged to a union that gave them
bargaining power at the firm level it
gave them a voice
at the firm level and also gave them
political power
because when you consider a third of all
workers unionized
the unionized segment of the workforce
actually had a political voice
now today by contrast to 50
years ago only 6.4 percent of private
sector workers
are unionized which means that at the
level of the firm
there is almost no union presence in
most firms
at the level of national politics the
union
voice is far less the working class
voice
is far less and so in both respects and
at both levels you get this severe
imbalance in the 1950s we talked about
the countervailing power
represented by american labor unions
countervailing
to the great power of american
corporations countervailing power is now
gone
there is almost no countervailing power
left
and so you it's not that the gm worker
was
that much more brilliant or productive
or
uh the gm worker was so much uh better
prepared
than the walmart worker no uh the the
difference really was that the gm worker
had a union behind
him or her and the walmart worker does
not all right with that i'm gonna have
to interrupt you and i apologize but i
want to ask
uh some of the other panelists the
question let me go to
uh jennifer bates uh miss bates let me
ask you a very simple question
and uh why do you believe it is so
important
for you and your co-workers to have a
union at the amazon facility in bessemer
alabama why is that so important
it's important because we need
a evil playing field for so long people
have been walking away from jobs
because of the disrespect and equality
and nobody has actually stood up to say
you know what it's time
for someone to be held accountable for
what they're doing
amazon has a sign that sits outside and
says
us if you see something say something so
we decided to stand up and say something
we need better um
work conditions we need a better wage
for living um we need
job security so it's important for us
that the union come in
so that amazon will have the opportunity
then to sit down and talk to us and with
us to get these issues resolved
okay thank you very very much
uh let me ask ms anderson a question
ms anderson according to your testimony
in 1980 ceos of large corporations made
about 42 times
more than their average worker today
ceos now make over 300 times
more than their average worker uh very
briefly
how did that happen
well it didn't happen because ceos just
got a whole lot smarter
during that time period uh on the worker
end it's happened because wages have
stagnated as unions have declined as
we've already discussed
on the ceo pay and it's happened because
stock-based pay
has come to dominate ceo pay packages
and
the argument there was that shifting to
stock-based pay
would ensure pay for performance and
that has really turned into a joke um
study after study shows there's no
connection between ceo pay levels and
their performance and
one of the most obvious examples was
after the
2008 financial crash when companies gave
boatloads of new stock options to their
executives when the market was at bottom
and very quickly those stock options
ballooned in value
as a result of a taxpayer fuel recovery
not because of any brilliant executive
performance
okay well thank you very much and my
time has expired
senator graham thank you mr chairman
uh let's start with uh secretary raj
what should yeah can you hear me
hello i can hear you perfectly fine
senator okay thank you mr secretary uh
what should the top individual tax rate
be uh in your view
uh well i under president eisenhower
um dwight eisenhower you may recall
uh the top rate
okay the top marginal rate was 91
uh the top effective rate was about 43
i don't need i don't think we need to go
back to uh
the eisenhower years uh he was a great
president in many respects
uh but i think that uh we do need to uh
substantially
increase uh the top marginal rate from
what it is today
and it's not just on instagram just
generally speaking what would that look
like i mean you don't have to give me an
exact number
uh well i would say probably in the
range of 40 to 50 percent
okay um what should the corporate tax
rate be
um are you are you asking me again
senator
yes yes sir uh i would say that the the
corporate rate
uh probably ought to be and again we're
talking about
income taxes uh corporate income taxes i
think that the
top corporate income tax rate ought to
be around
uh 30 percent uh maybe 35 percent
of where it was before uh but um
the question with corporate taxes is
always interesting because that's
the real underlying question is who who
ultimately pays
i'm one of the people who thinks that
maybe we ought to reduce the corporate
income tax
and increase capital gains taxes because
it really is shareholders
who uh who bear or should bear most of
the
burden uh of the corporate income tax
what should the capital gains rate
be uh i think the capital gains rate
should be probably around 25
or 28 that would be my best
guess uh warren buffett obviously thinks
that
there ought to be a minimum 30 percent
uh income tax and that would be
including capital gains uh i think he
may be
he may be right okay do you support
school choice for neighborhoods
who have poor performing public schools
uh again if you're asking me senator i
i support uh school choice in the same
who need to be held accountable
uh the real question is what the choice
is i think that
any uh organization
uh whether it's a charter school or a
public school
ought to be in the position of offering
a good education
uh and i've offered a a proposal years
ago
nobody supported it except jeb bush
governor jeb bush like this idea
which was a a voucher that would be
inversely related to family income
well that's very very helpful thank you
mr letteri
are you are you there
oh yeah okay do you support school
choice
uh for poor performing schools for
parents to have a choice
senator graham uh it's an important
question but it falls outside of the
scope of my organization's work so i'm
happy to offer you my
my personal opinion but i just want to
make it clear it's not uh not an issue
that we've studied in eig
that's that's okay uh about the tax
rates that i've just talked about
what's your view on tax rates
i think the question about where tax
rates should be set is a complicated one
because it depends on what other aspects
of the code
uh are a factor so deductions and
exemptions right
exactly so i i think what we know about
the corporate tax rate for example is
that the
uh would you support us would you
support a flat tax
no okay do you support tax reform
to eliminate some deductions and
exemptions
yes okay as a general matter i think
a simpler tax code is good a progressive
tax code is good
uh and uh and so i think if that's what
you mean by tax reform then the answer
is yes
yeah so my point here is if you wanted
to
improve the life of the average american
worker
at what point does regulation and
taxation
on business trickle down
to the inability to get good paying jobs
and a growing economy
how much do
the things that's often misunderstood is
that complexity is a subsidy to larger
incumbent
stakeholders so the more complex an
economy is the more complex the
regulatory system or the tax code is
the more likely it is to be gamed by
those at the top
and the more likely it is to
disadvantage those at the bottom uh
so as policymakers think about these
questions which are important
uh i think the the uh implicit barrier
to entry that's created by complexity
is something that you should keep in
mind because it's uh it's something that
certainly plays into the theme of
uh robust competition and holding larger
stakeholders one more competition yeah
one last question
uh do you worry that if our tax rates
are out of line on the corporate side
with the rest of the world
that will incentivize american companies
maybe to leave
i i think certainly that tax rates can
be a disincentive
uh it's not the only factor that
companies consider when they're looking
at vocational
decisions trade policy for example plays
a large role but certainly
if the u.s were to get way out of black
with the oecd average i think that would
be a problem
okay senator graham thank you senator
whitehouse
thank you chairman um my
questions are for um mr
reich um first of all thank you for your
testimony in your graphs
um you document unprecedented income
inequality in this country
basically since the gilded age which on
its own
is a problem but the question i want to
raise with you is
what do the new age robber barons do
with that money
the one percent billionaires we know
that some of them start
big famous foundations and they do
charitable work and good for them
but some of them set up faux foundations
and fund fake think tanks
and go to work in politics
from hiding many of them are
billionaires who made their billions in
the fossil fuel industry
and the operation that they run with
their billions can actually
best be compared in my view to hostile
covert operations like intelligence
services
run and so the question is what happens
when income inequality at
virtually unprecedented levels spawns
political inequality what happens when
you have a quietly ruling political
class
that is hiding behind dark money outlets
to control political parties to control
public debate
to control elections through sponsored
think tax
through captive paid for media outlets
and through dark money funded super pacs
and independent
expenditure political operations could
you comment on
there's that old line in uh tv
advertising but wait there's more
can you comment on the but wait there's
more of the political inequality
that the political hidden use of all
this massive fortune that they've
aggregated
is brought to bear
uh yes senator and this is really one of
the most
important negative consequences
of wide inequality and the degree of
inequality we have in the united states
today that is
people at the top who are sitting on top
of huge amounts of assets
can and do use a lot of that money to
influence
political decisions not only at the
federal level
but also at the state and local level
that
in turn increases their wealth
it's a vicious cycle we see for example
amazon in seattle has spent a great deal
of money
on city council elections amazon
around the country has is large enough
that it can actually have an auction in
which it
extorts money from states and cities
around the country
for where its second uh headquarters is
going to be
dark money uh is proliferating around
the country
as is our corporate public relations
uh efforts to change public attitudes
in a direction that a corporation may
want
the whole role of money in our system
uh and the overwhelming dominance of
money from
big corporations as well as from very
wealthy individuals
polluting american politics is one of
the worst
aspects of inequality and as the great
lewis brandeis the justice
once said we have a choice in this
country we can either have a great
deal of money in the hands of a few
people or we can have a democracy
but we can't have both so what happens
to citizenship and to the citizenry
when a citizen can't tell who the actor
is on the political stage
when the ad doesn't say hi i'm exxon and
i approve this message
i'm coke industries or charles koch and
i approve this message
instead it says behind some phony front
group
americans for peace and puppies and
prosperity
approve this message and you go and look
up americans for peace and
puppies and prosperity and it's a male
drop what is the citizen left with
the citizen is left with no ability to
sift through
the messages that that citizen receives
as to their veracity and reliability
motive sometimes matters doesn't it and
if you hide the identity
you also hide the motive and you hide
the ability of the citizen to evaluate
the motive and therefore the veracity
indeed and the supreme court has
repeatedly said
as recently as in citizens united
senator as you know
uh that uh transparency will cure
all of the negative aspects of
great wealth and corporate wealth in our
political system
well that has not happened we don't have
the transparency congress has not
demanded it
and a lot of dark money and dark money
groups
and 401 c 5 4 501 c
4 groups make it impossible for the
citizens to know
who is actually providing what message
and i'll conclude by pointing out that a
great number of them are in the supreme
court right now
trying to undo that transparency part of
the
supreme court's citizens united holding
thank you secretary reich thank you
chairman
senator toomey uh thank you mr chairman
and thanks for holding this hearing
the title of which is the income and
wealth inequality
crisis in america and i think we ought
to start with
um asking ourselves is this really a
crisis is that the way we should think
about
especially the most recent trends
in income and wealth inequality um i
want to start with uh
a chart that mr reich has provided us
he refers to it as the wage and salary
income
has dropped as a percent of gdp and this
is the chart he provides in his
testimony and you know if you look at it
it does look like
you know that's a declining trend right
it was kind of pronounced since 2000.
you could argue it goes back further but
yeah it looks like
that's sure looks like it's declining
but what's really interesting is that mr
rights chose
not to provide all the data that's
available he cuts off the data
in 2018. the data for 2019 and 2020
are available and so let's take a look
at what the picture looks like if you
include all the available data
if you include all the available data
what you notice
is it's the same graph except we've got
this very significant uptick
in fact it's an upward trend
from 2011 clearly an upward trend
in fact in 2018 and 2019
the upward trend now mind you what we're
talking about here is wages and salaries
as a percentage of our total economy
the upward trend that's been underway
for 10
years now was accelerating
in 2018 2019 further in 2020
so should we consider that we're in a
crisis
of income inequality when the situation
has been
trending better for 10 years
and most recently at an accelerating
pace
take a look we've recaptured back where
we were in 2003.
i think when you've got more available
uh more data available you're really
ought to use it
let's take a look at another chart that
we have here this is from the atlanta
fed
and it compares wage growth for the
lowest
25 percent of wage earners to the wage
growth
of the highest 25 percent of earners
now the lowest
25 percent of earners is in blue and the
highest 25 percent
of earners is in this gold color and
what does this chart show it's
it shows clearly that sometime around
about 2014
wages started growing more rapidly for
low-income workers
then wages have been growing for
high-income workers
and what does that mean that means the
income gap
is getting narrower right if if
higher income people's raises are
occurring at a lower pace than low
income raises
raises then the income differential is
narrowing and that's exactly what's
happening and once again
not only is that happening but it's
happening at an accelerating pace
because you see the gap
by which low-income earners are
outperforming
high income earners in terms of their
wage growth
that gap has widened so again does
an acceleration at the rate at which
lower income earners are gaining
ground relative to high income workers
when that's
happening and accelerating should we
think of that as a crisis
really and the reason i'm concerned well
let's go to one more chart here
we've got another one that's provided by
the st louis fed
and it's uh from the the data itself
comes from the u.s bureau of labor
statistics
and this is a depiction of average
hourly earnings
of production and non-supervisory
employees
so these are not managers they're not
executives
and what's happening is wages have been
rising and you know prior to 2015
not at a very spectacular pace that's
for sure but it's certainly been
accelerating to the point where in
recent years
these wage gains have been well above
the rate of inflation
so my point is this is very good news
i know some would like to suggest that
we have a crisis
so as to justify various socialistic
policies and
even more redistribution of wealth but
the fact is
the income gap has been narrowing and
it's been narrowing
at an accelerating pace a quick word
about the wealth gap
you know one of the ironies of this is a
big source of the
increase in the wealth gap has been the
inflated value of financial assets and
why have financial assets
gone up so much in value well a big part
of it i think
is ultra easy money by the federal
reserve our democratic colleagues
have long been huge advocates of ultra
easy money by the federal reserve
well you should be careful what you wish
for because this is one of the
consequences but even here
there is good news and the good news is
that
while investing in financial assets used
to be the domain of just the wealthy
that is increasingly becoming a
activity of middle income and even
people of modest means
and 20 in 1989 fewer than one-third of
american households own stocks
in 2019 a majority almost 53 percent of
american household
owned stocks this is going to help
narrow the wealth gap and i see i have
consumed my time thank you for indulging
me mr chairman
thank you senator uh senator van hollen
should be with us
on video
uh thank you thank you mr chairman and
ranking member and all our witnesses
um uh for your testimony
um we have seen another explosion in
terms of the gaps
between ceo compensation
and the compensation that they provide
to their
workers and that is why i
joined senator sanders in introducing
the bill we did today
but i'd like to talk and start um with
you dr reich
with the danger of using sort of
economic average measures uh to
measure how the overall economy is
performing
for working people so
for example if jeff bezos
had moved to baltimore city
last year you would have seen a tripling
of the per capita income in baltimore
city
the current per capita income in
baltimore city is roughly
53 000 if jeff bezos moved there last
year
uh would have more than triple that to
roughly 175 thousand dollars
per person and of course the situation
of any individual in baltimore city
would not have changed at all and so
looking from the outside of those
averages
you would say wow what's going on in
baltimore city
huge increase in economic activity
can you talk about why we really need to
be drilling down
on different economic measures in order
to gauge the success of our policies for
most americans
aggregate measures uh that simply look
at
the the average
and the average as you get more and more
unequal
in terms of income and wealth the
average tells you less and less about
how most people are living
even the median which is half above half
below
gives you more information but still
doesn't tell you
what you need to know about what's
happening to the bottom half
the biggest story of america over the
last 50 years
has been really the fact that the bottom
half what we used to call
the middle class and the working class
and the poor that
their situation have become so
similar and their
insecurities and the
degree to which they are living
paycheck to paycheck have have really
become very central to our political
economy
i think one reason that we find so many
people
who are poor and working class uh
are so angry uh is is justifiable their
anger is justifiable
and they've worked they worked harder
and harder and they get getting less and
less
mobility economic mobility the ability
of
to move upward is becoming harder and
harder for the bottom half
logically because as the ladder becomes
longer and longer
even if you are moving up the ladder at
the same rate you used to
move up the ladder that you get fewer
and fewer wrongs up that ladder
so you're absolutely a 100 correct we
need to look at
median and below not at average to
to get a real insight into what's
happening to the american workforce
well i i appreciate that and i hope we
will do that because
we tend to throw around numbers about
aggregate
gdp growth and those really disguise
what's happening to so many working
americans and of course um
this is all we've seen the drop in real
wages uh
since the late 1970s uh
coincide with many factors including
globalization but certainly a big one
is the drop in union um
membership uh and activity and that's
what the pro
act uh is designed to address
um if i could just ask jennifer bates to
let us know first thank you for what you
and your fellow workers are doing uh to
try to
organize um and empower workers can you
tell us um what you think a difference a
union would make to you and your
colleagues at amazon
what a union what the difference it will
make it will uh
allow us to feel more comfortable with
coming to work we are ready to come in
there with
with commitment but we will come to work
understanding
that uh things are being fair with us
we're able to sit down
and negotiate better working conditions
to get some of the issues resolved in
the facility
that it will allow us to come to work
and not have to worry about just getting
fired
for something that you have no idea that
you had done
uh it helps us um to
be put in a position where we're able to
negotiate
a living wage and not just the minimum
wage just on yesterday one of my
co-workers tried to apply for an
apartment
and they told us she didn't make enough
and if we would do this study we'll
understand that you have to make at
least 39 000
average to uh afford an apartment
so it would uh open the eyes not just uh
in bessemer alabama but all over that
the corporations
uh soon pay attention to the
working-class people
that um we're living paycheck to
paychecks trying to get
uh to not just pay the rent or pay
mortgage
but we also have to live uh
put food on the table so uh i think the
union
uh coming to bessemer alabama to amazon
will really open the door to a lot of
things
thank you miss bates we turn that to
senator johnson
thank you uh mr chairman i wish chairman
sanders were here because i i wanted to
second first of all what lindsay was
talking about how i think this
these hearings are very interesting i
think they're also very important
and i would just talk to my democrat
colleagues i think there's an awful
lot of areas of potential agreement here
on on this particular issue
i'm not so sure that it's the
accumulation of wealth that's the the
main problem here
i think it's the accumulation of power i
think
lindsay was kind of referring to that
with his monopolistic power
when i went to eastern europe and i know
senator senator whitehouse you've been
to munich conference when you go to
eastern europe they always talk about
the corruption of the media oligarchs
well
we have something similar here as well
so you can measure
the income disparity but you cannot you
can measure
uh asset disparity uh i don't have the
big charges they send it to me but
you know here's one way to look at
income disparity
and i'll do it for the cameras uh this
is
just simply the five quintiles you know
income earners broken up in 20
increments and you can see
when you're just looking at income it's
a 26 times
difference between the lowest quintile
in the upper quintile
but it completely changes when you
take away taxes from the upper quintile
and you add benefits
to the lower quintile then it's only
three times differential
so we can all talk about statistics we
can all
use them to i guess support our
arguments but what i would argue or what
i'd like to
say is let's let's kind of get together
on this uh i think
we do recognize that there is a problem
uh
and we have to diagnose what caused it
and i see senator kaine is back here
i've been
talking to him a little bit about in in
the past even with the republican
tax plan i was not a big fan of it quite
honestly i voted for it because i think
we
we did need to make our tax system more
competitive but
at the time i was i was promoting uh
something i thought would be
a better approach which is tax
simplification
and tax rationalization i mean to me
income is income
the fact that we have so many different
types of income that we just arbitrarily
assign different tax rates distorts
economic activity i think one of the
reasons you see this asset bubble
is we've created so many incentives for
c corporations to retain earnings
so they don't they don't flow out to
their shareholders they're not
efficiently reallocated in in through
our economy so one of the things i was
proposing is what i would call the true
warren buffett tax
uh 95 of american businesses are passed
through entities
the income is taxed at the individual
level
at individual rates so why not do it to
100 of corporations tax all corporate
income
at the individual level at individual
rates
incomes income uh we've
you know worked worked out all
complications it's actually quite easy
to do
i know it's a departure but i would love
to work with
my colleagues across the aisle and my
republican colleagues as well to
rationalize and simplify our tax system
capital gains you know the reason we
have a lower capital gains rates makes
some sense because
you don't want to tax mere inflationary
gains
but from my standpoint the better way of
doing it is call income income
taxed at the same rate but remove the
inflationary gain by index
indexing the asset again simplify
rationalize the tax system i i i don't
like
social or economic engineering through
the tax code we need to simplify it we
need to rationalize it
and i guess i just want to ask mr
winship
first of all no let me go to professor
wright first
do you disagree with this chart where
i'm showing
you know income without taking account
income taxes and benefits
20 ticks 26 time differential but when
you add in
income taxes or deduct income taxes and
add benefits which by the way
according to phil graham 45 000
average benefits from different welfare
programs tax credits the lowest 20
percent in 2020 alone
real disposal income went up 5.5
total savings up 1.6 trillion dollars
you know our economy is going to take
off with all the pent-up demand but did
you dispute this professor wright
um senator uh no i think that the
undoubtedly
when you add in taxes and transfers uh
unique
inequality of income uh becomes far less
dramatic
uh and that's an argument i i assume uh
for more taxes and more transfers but uh
also let me just stress that wealth
inequality
is not really touched by that and one of
the biggest problems we have in this
country
uh in terms of everything from political
influence
to the distortions that we that occur
when uh great wealth is transferred from
family to family from
generation to generation uh has to do
with wealth inequality
uh and not uh only income inequality
thank you secretary it's senator kane's
time now
[Music]
thank you chair and fellow colleagues
and senator johnson the income has
income something i really believe in too
so there
may be some profitable discussions there
um i have a chart with me that i hope
might be visible uh behind me depending
upon the camera angle
um it's not right now i wonder thank you
for that
and this chart is an interesting chart
because i think it shows the
different values of the two parties
right now but it also
shows potentially a different economic
philosophy
that we can operate a real-time
experiment on so
this takes a look at how the benefits in
the trump 2017 tax
cut the tax cut and jobs act were
allocated among the five economic
quintiles of the american public
and then it also shows how the benefits
of the american rescue plan
passed in february by democrats
were allocated among the american public
and if you look
at the chart what you see is a couple of
things the
the quintile of the american public that
was most benefited by the trump
tax cut was the top quintile the
quintile benefited by the
democratic american rescue plan was the
lowest quintile
um 65 of the benefit in the trump tax
cut went to the top
quintile whereas 65 more than 65 percent
of the benefit in the american rescue
plan went to the bottom three quintiles
the democratic recovery plan
was relatively even in distribution and
benefits
across the first four quintiles of
american income
uh whereas you see a dramatic unwaiting
and a lack of evenness in the republican
tax cut in jobs act um given that the
republican tax plan was passed with
unanimous republican support and no
democratic support
and the american rescue plan was passed
with unanimous democratic support and no
republican support i think
these two plans are a really interesting
window into the values
of the two parties and the price tags of
both plans were essentially the same the
tax
cut plan was about 1.9 trillion the
american rescue plan
was about or 1.8 trillion
um so i think this is a great chart and
the coincidence of which bars are blue
and which bars are red are
is not a coincidence but i think it's a
great chart to show the different
philosophies
in the two parties as to how you want to
allocate benefits if the
the government does something like this
that's supposed to be
a stimulus in nature the democratic
proposal is to spread it more evenly
with a little bit more focus on the
lowest earning americans the republican
philosophy is to concentrate benefits at
the top
but what i'm interested in and this is
the question i would like to pose to the
panelists
is in addition to expressing the values
of the parties i also think we're now
going to set up a really interesting
two-year study of what the effect of
these
proposed what the effect of this
legislation is on the american economy
so the the republican tax cut was done
in december of 2017 and you can run a
two-year experiment
december 2017 to december 2019
you wouldn't want to get too much into
2020 because covet is what economists
would say it is an exogenous shock so
you run a two-year study and then you
run a two-year study on the american
rescue plan from february of 2021 until
february 2023
and what you do and i i would encourage
maybe some of my academic friends on
this to do this
is look at every economic data point you
think is significant family income
employment poverty rates among adults
and children
stock market business startup activity
gdp
wealth inequality deficit you pick the
economic measure
and for the tax cut and jobs act you
start in december 2017 and you look at
how it affected the economy for two
years
and for the american rescue plan you
start in february of 2021
and you look how it affected the economy
in the next two years
and i think you'll see not only what the
values of the party are
the parties are but i think you'll also
see which economic philosophy actually
produces more good
for american society so that's a working
hypothesis
that i would put on the table to our
experts and i'd love anyone
who's on the panel to address whether my
hypothesis might
be worthy of study
well perhaps i could jump in this is
sarah anderson from the institute for
policy studies and i i really
appreciate your call for more analysis
of the impacts of
these policies on inequality and and the
whole
range of income levels i would perhaps
suggest an additional indicator for you
to look at
no one today has yet mentioned the
federal reserve figure
from 2019 that found that 40
of americans could not afford a 400
emergency meaning they were just one
medical problem or
car breakdown away from financial rune
and i think that's one of the most
powerful indicators that really gets at
how it's not just about wages
it's it's about the cost of living and
for so many americans the cost of
housing and health care just skyrake
skyrocketed and
it's a very concrete way of looking at
how that affects people's
level of economic uh security at a time
when we have a growing number of
billionaires at the top so
thank you
i might love to hear answers from some
of the other witnesses for the record i
am why don't we
we're waiting for senator braun who is
on his way here
so in the spirit of uh equivalence why
don't we
have senator johnson ask a question have
senator kane ask a question
and then go oh here's senator braun
saving the day coming in
just in the nick of time for his time
so i will uh recognize
senator braun if you want to take a
moment to get yourself squared away we
can
uh okay very good
and chairman sanders is back from the
vote so
he can resume
the gavel
[Music]
thank you mr chair so listening to
uh the opening remarks uh
i've got this to say when it comes to
what happens with minimum wage when it
what happens with
income inequality i think both are valid
issues when it comes to how you
tackle it the difference between main
street
usa small businesses
family-owned even mid-size businesses
it's a lot different
than in my opinion public corporations
where you've got a different dynamic at
play
when you look at income inequality you
got to be careful
because the opposite of that
ends up where you get a central
government
to overbearing that's not worked
anywhere uh where it's occurred and when
you look at
how did we get into the pickle that
we've gotten into currently
i think a lot has to do with many of the
major sectors of our economy
and i'd cite health care for instance
you're dominated
by a system that has no transparency
has no competition has barriers to entry
and doesn't have an engaged consumer the
hallmark
of what makes markets work so
i think when you hear discussions of
well amazon is paying 15 bucks
an hour to me for a huge corporation
it's got the wherewithal probably should
be more than that
when you look at wage uh across the
country
i i think that something needs to be
done with the minimum wage but then you
need to look at it
from a regional point of view you don't
want to disrupt
places like indiana where it's working
because you've got a great business
climate
you've also got a low cost of living so
if you do anything with minimum wage it
ought to be done
to where you regionalize it places like
new york city
san francisco seattle probably should be
over 20 bucks an hour because their cost
of living
is so high but when you took go to the
extreme of uh what's been
talked about here i think you end up
maybe hurting uh in the long run if you
try to bring the federal government
in as someone that tries to moderate the
situation
other than maybe making sure that
markets are free
and unfettered and that they're
competitive and sadly
when you look at many of the places
where public companies
and corporations rule you do not have
that
so i've got a the other thing is when
you look at the
structural deficits that we run in this
country of close to a trillion dollars a
year
my first question uh if he's still on
would be for uh
mr wright that how do you
uh without upsetting an economy that i
think was working
fairly decently you were raising wages
the old-fashioned way
uh pre-covered how do you bridge
a structural deficit but it's mostly
associated with programs like social
security
medicare medicaid that we need but that
aren't
self-sustaining and i love your
explanation
can you raise revenues
in any way that it's not going to upset
the economy that to me there's a sweet
spot
and corporate rates when they were moved
from 35 to 21
affecting corporate tax rates were 18
largely due to all the exceptions in the
code
you talked main street employers
actually got a tax break that i think
was driving the economy when you took
the qualified income deduction
and took that rate from 39.6 to 29.6
i love to hear your comments on how you
what your idea is on revenue without
upsetting the economy
uh well senator we've learned that the
deficit and the overall federal debt
is less of a threat than we thought it
was
as recently as even 20 years ago
in terms of inflation and inflationary
expectations
but at some point uh we do need to raise
revenue
and the question obviously becomes where
and how and who is going to pay
the subject of these hearings uh is
widening inequality
of income and wealth and it would seem
to me that if we're looking for
places to raise revenue assuming that we
come to the point where we say well
given the needs of this country we do
have to raise revenue
uh that the place to look is certainly
at the top and i
i think that the proposals for a wealth
tax
merit a great deal of attention other
countries
have a wealth tax we have property taxes
at the local level a form of wealth tax
it seems to me that
given the extraordinary wealth uh in
the hands of certain people in this
country uh wealth taxes
is appropriate we also need to uh
get rid of the loopholes uh loopholes
that we've been talking about for years
like the carried
interest loophole there's no reason for
it
and there are many other loopholes as
well that have been put into the tax
code
because there are companies and
industries that are
hiring lobbyists uh that uh have
really spent all their time looking for
ways of creating
way uh methods to reduce tax liability
let's get rid of those loopholes uh and
let's uh let's make sure that the base
is as wide as possible thank you do i
have time for one quick follow-up
well over time but i'll give you if it's
a brief very brief
so a quick follow-up question uh
where does spending fit into the formula
when
we've had record revenues of recent
years how much of a deficit are you
willing to tolerate under the maybe new
modern monetary theory
um well senator we don't know
uh all that much quite frankly uh as to
modern
monetary theory it's a fairly new idea
the mainstream notion and i i i think
that we
we don't want to make take too many
risks i
i think that at some point the deficit
and deficit financing and the total
federal debt
could ignite inflationary expectations
uh and that's why we do have to get some
to get serious about uh about raising
revenue
uh the the easiest place to raise
revenue as i just said
is from people who are very wealthy it
has the least dampening effect on the
economy
but right now however when there is so
much
underutilized capacity in terms of
nine and a half million americans who
have lost their jobs
four million americans who have dropped
out of the wage labor
force altogether uh something in the
order of 15 million americans
who are working part-time who'd rather
be working full-time
given all of this under-utilized
capacity
right now we do need to spend in order
to stimulate the economy i don't think
there's any question about that
and there's a great deal of consensus
about that uh
with regard to the mainstream thank you
okay thank you very much uh i believe
our last
question over senator luhan senator
chair sanders thank you so very much and
thanks to you and to ranking member
graham for
today's hearing and i look forward to
having a conversation about the
importance of unions to our democracy
our republic and
to working americans mr chair my family
raised me to understand that our
communities are stronger when
workers are protected and empowered my
grandfather was a union carpenter
my dad was a union iron worker and local
495
my mom worked for the local public
school district my brother's ibw
and my nephew just was accepted into an
apprenticeship program with ibw
i believe that everybody in america
should have the same opportunity that my
grandfather
fathers siblings and nephew have had to
work hard to
build real economic security and to pass
something better
onto your children and grandchildren
those are the values i grew up
learning and those are the values that i
continue to fight for today
the testimony we heard today from our
witnesses includes
a number of striking statistics and
that's where my questions will begin
mr latieri how much wealth does the
bottom fifty percent of families own
uh senator that would be two percent and
miss anderson what is the current pay
gap between corporate ceos
and the average workers over 300 to one
and mr reich how much of its value has
the minimum wage lost to inflation
since it was last raised in 2009
just about 10 percent and mr reich how
much has union membership
fallen over the past half century
uh from 32 of private sector workers
down to 6.4 of private sector workers
today
so down about 33 since 1950
mr reich yes or no would you agree that
these statistics and
increased inequality are correlated with
the decline in union membership
i think they are directly correlated in
fact if you look
at the rise of unions in terms of the
percentage of americans in the private
sector were unionized
and then the decline of unions you see
that the
peak years of unionization were from
1940
to 1978 and those were exactly the years
when we had the greatest degree of
equality in this country
in terms of uh income and wealth spread
much more equitably than today and
miss bates i very much appreciate having
you here today
and i want to make sure that i give you
some time to answer this question
and it's similar to a question that you
were asked earlier so my question in
spades is
what would having the opportunity to
join a union
mean to you and to your co-workers
what having a union uh will bring to me
uh will mean to me and my co-workers is
that um
we our voices are being amplified that
will give us
even playing field we'll be able to
negotiate a better pay wages
which means there's a living wage and
not just the minimum wage that amazon
uh voices um what it would mean is that
we will have job security that people
won't get fired for mundane things or be
afraid that they're going to get fired
for doing something that they had no
idea of doing uh will bring us respect
and bring us a sense of empowerment that
when we stand
that we believe continue to believe that
we are valued
uh bring the value and commitment that
we bring into the uh
the jobs that we receive the same thing
so having a union
um to amplify what we are saying it will
bring us a sense of security
and not just at the amazon investment
but all over the country
ms bates all i have to say to that is
amen i want to thank you for being here
today well i appreciate the expertise of
the panelists and the witnesses and
especially the
expertise that i've benefited from the
work that he has done as a secretary of
labor
but all of his advocacy and secretary
reich your testimony today has been
very compelling and i just want to say
thank you so much for
coming today and again to the chair and
to the ranking member for bringing us
together
and with that chair sanders i yield back
well thank you very much
uh senator i'm not sure if we are going
to have
another senator or not join us but let
me
wrap up um this
uh hearing by thanking all of the
panelists and all the senators
who participated the issue that we are
dealing with today
income and wealth inequality
is an issue that has to be addressed
and it's an issue that will determine
what kind of nation we wish to become
we are the wealthiest nation in the
history of the world
but the truth is that half of our people
are living paycheck to paycheck
many millions of people are working for
starvation wages
and as a result of the pandemic people
are wondering how they're going to feed
their kids how they're going to avoid
eviction how they're going to go to the
doctor when they or another family
member gets sick clearly i think
our goal is to create a nation
where the economy works for all people
and not just the very few
but that's in fact where we are right
now and as i think some of the
discussion this morning has been about
is that it's not only
the absurdity of two people in america
owning more wealth than the bottom
half of the country it is the kind of
power
that the people on top have to hire
lobbyists here in washington
to influence legislative decisions to
own
media uh to make campaign
contributions there is a reason why the
rich get richer and so many other people
are becoming poorer
and that is not just economic decisions
but those are political decisions
as well and too often those decisions
are influenced by the people who have
the money
so uh this is an issue i think this was
an excellent hearing and i thank all of
um our panelists for participating and
we look forward to pursuing this issue
in the months to come uh thank you all
very much and this hearing is ended
but
you